>>Ray Cromwell: Hi.
Good afternoon.
Welcome to the history and future of Google
Web Toolkit.
My name is ray Cromwell, I'm tech lead for
GWT.
So I'd like to just jump right in because
we've got seven years, believe it or not,
of history to cover.
So, often people actually come up to me and
say why did Google even create GWT in the
first place?
Isn't JavaScript good enough for you?
Why do you need Java for Web programming?
So I think it's instrumental to go back and
look at the context in which GWT was conceived
seven years ago.
So if you think back seven years ago, which
is an eternity in Web time, Web 2.0 was just
starting, AJAX apps, rich internet applications
were just being created, the first sort of
series of them.
And people were actually thinking back then
that the future of rich internet applications
was going to be something like a war between
Adobe Air and Microsoft Silverlight.
I mean, there were conventions on this.
And people did not think that the browsers
were powerful enough to do really, really
capable applications.
And then Google released Gmail in 2004 and
Google Maps in 2005, and I think that started
to change people's imagination because for
the first time, especially with Google Maps,
people saw an application that was written
in the Web that was fast, it was fluid, it
was -- in fact, this was before touch.
It was touchable.
The way you interacted with the Google Maps
application is you grabbed it with the mouse
pointer and flung the map around.
So that fired up people's imagination and
people really wanted to start building rich
Web applications like this.
But at the time if you looked around and surveyed
the landscape there wasn't a lot of good tools
to do this in just raw JavaScript by hand.
In fact, jQuery, which is really the most
popular library out there, wasn't even released
until 2006.
And I think probably Bruce Johnson and Joe
Weber who created GWT were sitting around
somewhere in a cafe and saying How can we
solve this problem without building our own
JavaScript bidi, JavaScript testing frameworks
and build servers and all this other kind
of stuff that's been there for a long time.
And if you look at Java they were like wow,
it has seven million programmers, it has intelliJ
and Eclipse, it's got Ant and Maven and it's
got J Unit and Test Mg and it has bug analysis
software and dependency package management
and all this stuff.
The only thing you can't do with it is you
can't write a client side Web application
except if you want to do applets or something.
If I could only compile Java to JavaScript
it would close the loop and we would get massive
leverage on that ecosystem.
So that I think was the foundation context
for GWT.
So it's evolved a lot since then.
The first version of GWT was released in 2006,
followed very shortly by a few other versions
that really didn't add much to fix bugs.
The really important thing is with GWT 1.3
in 2007 early on we released it as open source.
And for the first time everyone could contribute
to GWT if they wanted to.
And it was also the first to get OSX support.
Later in 2007 we added J Unit testing framework
support as well as automatic sprite sheeting.
This was another first because back in 2007
we were automatically creating CSS sprite
sheets on the fly well before actually people
had built tools to do this for hand-coded
JavaScript.
But the biggest thing people were asking us
over and over again is when are you going
to have Java 5 support?
We want generics, we want enoms, we want auto
boxing, all that stuff.
So they did a fire drill, they crunched down
and in 2008 they got Java 1.5 support.
In fact, 1.5 was one of the biggest releases.
It added not just Java 1.5 support, but this
new overlay type system that allowed you to
link with JavaScript for the first time with
zero overhead in the compiler.
It had a new low level DOM API, and we added
CSS themes to the widgets for the first time,
so everyone who used GWT early on knew that
the widgets no style whatsoever.
Out of the box it just looked like nothing.
So we added a couple of CSS themes so at least
out of the box someone could actually look
at the app and not puke.
[ Laughter ]
>>Ray Cromwell: And we added this thing called
linkers which has some useful things that
I can perhaps get into later.
And with 2009 we basically redid the event
handler system to make event handling more
generic and not just tied to the DOM.
Now you could fire custom events and reuse
events on both the client and in your server
code.
We added code coverage support with Emma.
We added war directory support so you could
just point our tools at a war directory and
it would work.
And we added a parallelized build system that
today is mostly used by Google.
In 2009 we had a minor release that mostly
just added support.
2009, though, was the year of a really big
release, and that was GWT 2.0.
And GWT 2.0 was an overhaul.
It was the biggest release ever.
We added a totally new dev mode so that you
could develop in development mode with any
browser you liked.
So whether it was Chrome or whether it was
IE, whether it was Safari, Firefox, you had
the same experience.
Previously we were bundling a really old version
of Firefox or IE directly into the GWT toolkit,
so you couldn't even upgrade the browser you
were developing with.
We added draft compilation to speed up your
compiles.
We added this new templating system called
UI binder.
We added layout panels for really efficient
CSS style layout.
And we added the code splitter, which was
an overhaul to compiler to allow you to tell
the compiler that certain pieces of code don't
need to be loaded when your app starts up,
but they can be loaded later.
And a new system for bundling resources into
your application, which was called client
bundle, which was the evolution of image bundle,
which did sprite sheets.
With client bundle we also bundle in CSS and
we have a CSS compiler that performs optimizations
on the CSS to shrink that down as well.
In 2010 we partnered with VMWare to support
their cloud, and that necessitated a new RPC
system that was not as tied to Java as GWT
RPC was, and that was request factory, which
was a more JSON oriented RPC framework.
We did data binding with the editor framework.
JSR 303 bean validation support, model view
presenter pattern support, and a new system
of cell widgets which are efficient widgets
for rendering like tables and grids.
Then we had a couple of minor releases.
We acquired this company called Instantiations
and we released as open source WYSIWYG designer
for GWT UIs.
We added a lot of HTML5 support, like canvas
and storage and things like that.
And we dropped in a little bit of stuff for
Google in terms of enhancing app integration.
And then finally, in the last release we sort
of started to think that we need to move off
Ant and get more towards Maven, so we sort
of Mavenized it.
So that's where we were.
That's the history of GWT.
So where are we today?
Well, as far as we can tell the SDK has been
downloaded over a million times, but that's
probably not an accurate number because a
lot of people are getting it from Maven central
now.
We have over 100,000 monthly active developers.
Because software basically periodically checks
to see if there's a new version to give you
a notification that GWT 2.5 is available.
So we at least know of Eclipse users there's
100,000 active developers.
We have deep integration with Eclipse through
the Google Eclipse plug-in with intelliJ and
with VMWare spring tools.
And our products are used widely within Google,
including our biggest product, which is AdWords,
Google Flights, Offers, Google Groups, Blogger,
many that you haven't even imagined that were
written in GWT.
And we did a couple of fun things.
We ported Quake, first-person shooter in 2009
using GWT to the Web and it ran smoothly at
60 frames per second in a browser, and Angry
Birds for the Web, if you've ever played for
Chrome, is written in GWT.
So GWT today is a mature, high quality code
base.
What more could we do?
Is there anything left to actually do to improve
GWT?
And I'm happy to say over the last year we've
done a lot.
In fact, the GWT 2.5 release that we're introducing
today is the largest release we've done, I
think, since GWT 2.1.
We've added more stuff in 2.5 than we did
in 2.2, 2.3, 2.4 put together.
Let me go over a few of them.
First, we did a lot of work on the compiler.
So out of the box with no changes to your
code, if you just recompile your application
you will get a substantial code size reduction.
For example, the showcase application, if
you just recompile the GWT 2.5, 14% smaller
JavaScript.
And that is undercounting because the GWT
user library has added a lot more bloat in
terms of the underlying library code.
So it probably would have been even smaller.
The mobile Web app, eight percent smaller.
Your mileage may vary.
The larger the app probably the better the
benefit.
Smaller apps, smaller benefit.
But we can do better.
We also integrated the JavaScript closure
compiler that is used at Google for like Gmail
and Google+ and Google Docs and a lot of other
large JavaScript applications.
And the closure compiler has a lot of really
low level JavaScript optimizations that we
never really would think to do in GWT because
it's Java oriented, things like putting bang
zero instead of true or if you have a number
like 10,000, rewrite it as 1E4 in scientific
language.
It saves off two bytes.
So here you can see if you enable closure
compiler you get an extra five percent co-size
reduction.
So now versus GWT 2.4, recompiled with the
switch closure compiler, we're 20% smaller
than GWT 2.4.
But we can do better.
We've also looked at the code splitter and
so the showcase application, for example,
does a live code splitting.
If you're not aware of what code splitting
does, it allows you to pick parts of your
application, like a composed window or settings
page, that may not be displayed immediately
when your application is loaded up.
You can mark them as split points that the
compiler has the option of deferring and loading
later.
So it can move that code out into a separate
JS file, shrinking the initial size of the
JS that has to be loaded.
So any bit of code that is exclusive to one
particular fragment and is not shared is called
exclusive code.
What I'm showing up here is there's split
points.
They have some code that is only referenced
within those split points, and if there is
some like, let's say, job util list that both
of them use, and so any time there's shared
code we put that code in a shared fragment
called the leftovers fragment.
Here's the problem.
As you continue to increase the number of
split points in your application, the probability
of there being shared code between any two
split points rises.
And what that means is that that leftovers
fragment at the bottom gets larger and larger.
So when your application loads up, before
it can run any of these split points it has
to load the leftovers fragment because it's
a shared library.
So we needed to do something about that leftovers
fragment.
What we do is we perform a kind of clustering.
We analyze all the fragments that you've split
out and looked for ones that are most similar,
that basically use the most amount of code
together, and we merge them into one fragment.
And hopefully there's a lot of shared code
that no longer is used by anybody else.
It's only used now within that new merged
fragment that you see in the middle of the
screen.
That leaves the leftovers fragment down at
the bottom empty where we've hoisted some
code out of it into this new shared fragment.
So what can of effect can this have on an
application like Showcase?
39% reduction in code size of the initial
JavaScript that your application has to load
before it can present the UI to the user.
The first time I saw this I thought we had
a bug in the compiler and it was wrong, it
was removing too much code, but I've measured
it several times and it's true.
39% code size reduction.
But there are other things we had to do.
We had to improve the overall diagnostics
of the compiler.
Things that you might rely on like if someone
is running your application and a user hits
an exception, how are you going to find out
what happened and what line of code it happened
on?
So there's this new standard that Google has
proposed and other people have adopted called
source maps.
What it does is whenever you compile anything
to JavaScript, be it Java, Closure, Coffee
Script, whatever, we write out the standardized
mapping file which says this piece of Java
or Coffee Script or whatever source language
became this bit of obfuscated JavaScript in
the output.
But having that bidirectional mapping, now
when you go to debug or inspect obfuscated
compiled JavaScript code, it can actually
tell you the original line of code that it
came from in your source language before you
messed with it.
So this permits de-obfuscation of script,
but it allows GWT, more importantly, to construct
perfectly accurate stack traces.
So right now today if the user encounters
like an exception in one of the GWT applications,
you get the line number of the method, the
name of the method that it occurred in, but
you actually don't actually get the actual
line number of code within the method that
it occurred on.
And in fact, if the compiler has inline several
methods and rolled them up into one, you actually
don't even know what method it occurred in
because now those small inline methods are
not even on the call stack.
They've been basically moved in to the parent
caller.
Not so with source maps.
Now you will actually know the exact original
function, regardless of optimizations, where
the error occurred.
It's Chrome only for now.
Firefox has demoed it and they promise to
support it.
Okay.
So this kind of dovetails into super dev mode
because it's what enables it.
But here's the problem.
Over the years people have complained we haven't
kept our dev mode, C++ plug-ins up to date.
Basically we use these native plug-ins that
we install into the browser so that when you
run in dev mode and it's running Java code
and it has to remote control the browser and
tell the browser add a DOM element somewhere,
it talks to this plug-in, which then remotes
controls the browser to actually update the
browser.
The problem is that the browser vendors have
accelerated their iteration on their browser.
Used to be they would release a browser once
a year, Firefox 4, 5, it would take a year.
That would give the GWT team more than enough
time to actually update three or four different
plug-ins on three or four different operating
systems.
But now we simply can't handle it because
every six weeks they're releasing a new version.
Like, for example, every time Firefox releases
a new version of Firefox it breaks the C++
plug-ins that we have.
So we needed a new solution.
Plus on things like mobile devices like iOS
you can't even have plug-ins in the browser,
so how would you debug a GWT application on
an iPad?
So what if we could create a GWT compiler
that was so fast we could compile your Java
code in one second?
Biggest complaint we get is the compiler is
slow.
So what if we could speed it up so we could
compile your code in one second or 10 seconds?
Then you could actually iterate by loading
up JavaScript into their browser.
And with the combination of source maps, you
actually could debug source level Java code
right in your browser.
So let me show you a demo of that.
So I've got the GWT code server running, which
is the new super dev mode server.
It's a servlet.
It starts up on your GWT module and basically
it's waiting there for me to connect.
It's going to serve up the compiled code.
So I'm going to go to this application I have
called Silver Comet, and hopefully I've got
a network connection and it can load up.
I might be in trouble here.
If that doesn't, what I'll do is I have another
version.
Here let's do this.
I'll just skip ahead for a second and I'll
come back to that and show it to you.
All right.
Let's let that go for a second.
Okay.
There it is.
So this is an application, it's graphing marathon
data from the Silver Comet half-marathon in
Atlanta.
You can see I can do things like I can hit
a character, click on a person, it tells me
where the runner is.
If I were to try to debug this today, I would
bring up the Chrome inspector and I go to
scripts.
You can see that it's basically compiled JavaScript.
So it would be really hard to like set a break
point in here and debug it.
So let's go down to here and click on this
little -- in the Chrome inspector this little
gearbox and say enable source maps.
So now I'm going to click this -- I'm going
to go back to the code server and I'm going
to drag this bookmarklet up here and I'm going
to turn on super dev mode.
So hopefully it's going to reload.
I think my network is having problems.
Okay.
There it is.
I'm going to click super dev mode, click compile.
And it's compiling.
And usually this takes like less than two
seconds, but network is loading already, so
it's already finished, but it's loading on
the bottom.
There we go.
Now it's reloading the compiled JavaScript.
It's already been compiled at this point.
I go over to this window over here and I can
probably show you compiled in 0.979 seconds,
if you can see that.
So the issue is there is some kind of network
thing that's hurting my demo here.
Let me bring up the inspector and see if I
can show this to you.
Oh, there it is.
So it's back up.
I'm going to go to the scripts tag now, scripts.
Now you can see I have Java code in here.
[ Applause ]
>>Ray Cromwell: And I promise you it won't
take this long when you actually do it on
your own computer.
I'm going to go and I can set a break point
here.
See that?
And I will come up here and hit a character
and you can see it doing a break point.
I can hit play and you see the things up there?
So I'm stepping through Java code.
In fact, you can do something in super dev
mode that you could never do in regular dev
mode.
I'm going to step down into a JSNI function.
I'm going to step into this item shell, step
into remove property, JSNI JavaScript function.
You could never do that before in regular
dev mode.
[Applause].
So let's go back to slides.
Okay.
UI binder.
If you use UI binder we have more good news
for you.
First of all, if you sell widgets, you can
now actually -- you don't have to write Java
code, you can actually specify the template
for a cell that renders in a table grid or
in a tree with a UI binder template.
There's sort of a new interface called UI
render and it does that.
Secondly, we have optimized the way UI binder
constructs the HTML and injects into the page
significantly.
We have vastly reduced the number of DOM operations
down to just a few.
The end result of that is start-up latency
for Orchid, which also uses GWT was reduced
by 20%, and the rendering speed it was taking
to refresh the HTML on the page went up by
300%.
So not just the compiler has been improved,
but the speed of the widgets has been improved
up to 300%.
And we've also started the beginnings of adding
support for using the same I 18 and message
class used on the client side in the server.
So using GWT.create in the server, and what
that will get to is sometimes you want to
share code between the client server in terms
of internationalization resource bundles,
this will basically get you there eventually.
And we have updated the ARIA library support
in the GWT to the newest W3C standard.
If you have accessibility concerns, we have
better support for that.
Lastly, we're introducing a new experimental
library called Elemental.
So what is Elemental?
Well, over the years, as I said, the browser
vendors are iterating faster and faster, every
week they are adding a new HTML5 API into
JavaScript.
And we just can't keep up hand wrapping those
APIs, so every release, GWT 2.2, 2.3, 2.4,
we added a few.
We added canvas and then we added local storage,
an index database, so on.
But there's just too many.
We can't keep it up as a manual process.
So what Elemental is, it's a library that
builds a complete 100% HTML5 mapping to the
latest Chrome, WebKit and soon Firefox, by
actually looking at the C++ source code definitions
for the JavaScript run times used for exporting
their APIs and auto generating a complete
set of GWT classes that directly call into
those APIs, look, it's all done -- I've got
a typo in there -- with JavaScript overlay
type.
So when you compile this, they all melt away,
it's a small or smaller than you could write
by hand.
There's no overhead.
Every API you could think of is there, WebGL,
Web audio sockets, RTC, even Web Intents,
Shadow DOM, these new things that you might
have just seen at the show today.
We have a new set of collection classes that
you can use as an alternative to JavaScript
util collections that are mapped directly
to underline JavaScript collections, so there's
no overhead if you use like maps or arrays,
no extra bloat.
And a new JSON library, similarly that has
no overhead if you use it, just directly access
JSON objects and no bloat in the output.
I think this is an excellent library for doing
mobile device development because the mobile
device browsers are often on the bleeding
edge of CSS3 and things like that because
that's how they get their extra performance.
So it could also work for desktop.
But you might have the -- already using the
existing stuff, so you will have to decide
whether or not you want to move over to this
library.
But try it out.
I'm going to show you a demo.
Real quick.
And I cooked up sort of a hack to show you
the power of super dev mode and to show the
power of Elemental.
And so what I have done is I've built this
servlet filter that if you try to load up
an HTML page and if you have something in
there like this ... I'm going to type a script
tag.
I'm going to say type the SQL to text/ -- no,
not JavaScript, Java.
And in here, I'm just going to write like
I would write JavaScript.
Window.alert.
Hello.
Believe it or not, that's Java code, not JavaScript.
So I have a servlet filter, when this file
is being piped out will catch that script
tag and see well, that's Java code, automatically
synthesize a GWT module entry point on the
fly, right into the super dev mode compiler,
compile it in one second, then replace it
back with a regular script type, text JavaScript,
and then the page loads.
And so -- so my computer is kind of slow on
a real computer -- if I would upgrade my computer
it would run a lot faster, but I will show
you that right now.
Let's see -- if I just write some code there,
and it's -- oops.
Wait.
Okay.
Is it running?
It is running.
Okay.
Demo problems again.
Oh, that's because it's on my local machine.
That would make all difference okay.
Let's let that load.
There you go.
[ Applause ]
>>Ray Cromwell: So now you can develop -- if
I were to release this servlet filter, you
can actually develop Java code in a really
lightweight fashion, where you can have multiple
HTML pages and just sprinkle a little bit
of Java code in each page a page at a time
and just get a little tiny bit of compiled
Java code out of it.
Well, why would you do that?
Well, simple.
Any of you know by heart the new Web RTC camera
API?
I sure don't.
There's a lot of APIs in HTML5.
But because this is Java, this is my Java
IDE, you know, I can do things like this,
you know, window -- this is the Elemental
library -- .getnavigator or .get -- you see
all of these APIs in geolocation, platform
plug-ins, product, I can do WebKitgetusermedia,
which is the new Web RTC API to access the
camera.
So you can get full completion, all of the
normal stuff that you love in your IPE, but
with the sort of lightweight HTML programming
experience.
So let's try that out and see if that works.
Going to take a second to recompile.
And hopefully this works.
There you go.
[ Applause ]
>>Ray Cromwell: So try this out, it's experimental,
but it has a lot of cool APIs in it to try
out.
Okay.
So you have seen the past, you have seen the
now, let's talk about the future.
So one of the problems that's been happening
over the last year or so is that ability to
iterate on GWT by taking outside community
contributions has slowed a lot.
The reason why, it has been paradoxically
due to GWT's success within Google.
So as more and more internal Google apps migrated
to GWT, we could not take much of a chance
accepting patches without thoroughly reviewing
them.
Imagine somebody submits a patch and it puts
a bug into ad words, we could lose billions
of dollars of revenue.
So we have to be really careful about accepting
external community patches.
So you might have noticed a lot of frustration
with the issue tracker because we had our
internal issue tracker, and we were proprietary
to internal bugs.
Hundreds of internal GWT apps, you know, our
internal customers come first, compared to
the community because that's where our money
is coming from.
And so -- so I thought that was a really sorry
situation to be in because a lot of the people
in the community have contributed so much
to GWT over the years and we really needed
to do them better.
And so I suggested and we adopted that we're
going to basically change the governor -- governing
body of GWT to no longer just be Google as
a dictator, but be as a peer.
So we're introducing the GWT steering committee.
So now the control over the future roadmap
of GWT, when features go into it, who gets
to be a committer, who is a code reviewer,
what patches get landed is now going to be
controlled by a committee of several of the
top, you know, star contributors to the GWT
community and some of the biggest companies
using GWT.
Google goes from being now a gatekeeper to
a peer amongst equals.
So we have to be more responsive, we have
to think more about what other people are
using GWT for, not only what we are using
it for.
The steering committee is going to determine
what the project guidelines are, what the
policies and philosophies of the project is
going forward and determine who gets direct
commit access to the master branch.
And it's going to set the overall future roadmap
as I said.
We have drawn from a mix of star contributors,
and here they are.
This is the initial GWT steering committee.
It's Google, Vaadin, Sencha, Red Hat, Thomas
Broyer, and Stephan Haberman, who have done
an enormous number of bug fixes to GWT over
the years.
Daniel Kurka, who has done an absolutely awesome
mobile GWT library, and Christian Goudreau
of Arcbees, who has done the GWT team library
which a lot of people use because it extends
our MVP library, it's really fabulous.
We've had some early decisions.
We've had a couple of meetings already.
We've decided, this might please many of you,
we're moving the DMT repository from Subversion
to Git.
[ Applause ]
>>Ray Cromwell: And we're going to have two
official branches now.
The master dev line trunk, where all of you
if you have a feature, you can submit your
patch, and it can land, whether or not it
may break an internal GWT application.
This will be the bleeding edge branch.
Everyone when you get a nightly build one
and try it out, we can figure out what needs
to be rolled back.
But if it makes it through the dev branch
and doesn't destroy anybody's applications,
then it's going to be cherry picked into the
beta branch, which represents the work on
the next release, let's say GWT 2.6 or GWT
3.0.
The beta release is what Google is going to
be building our internal apps off of.
So there's going to be a lot of quality assurance
on that branch so you can be sure if you want
to pick up something that's a little more
stable, you can be trusting in, that would
be beta branch.
Our partners like Sencha and Vaadin will probably
also be shipping code based off of beta branch
works, not the dev link.
So you will have a much lower probability
of breakage.
So here's where you will find us, there's
going to be a new website, not up yet.
It's google.com/gwtsteering.
You can read about all of the new rules, processes
for contributing to the GWT.
And there's a GWT steering mailing list where
you can read our meeting minutes and our discussions
on what's happening with the future of GWT
and where it's going.
So you won't to wait ages for a blog post
from us to see what's happening.
Now you can read it in real-time.
So now I would like to ask Michael Mullany,
CEO of Sencha, to talk about all of the brave
and exciting things that they're going to
do with GWT now and in the future.
[ Applause ]
>>Michael Mullany: Awesome, it's great to
be here.
My name is Michael Mullany, I run Sencha.
Also joined by Darrell Meyer here in the audience
who is a tech lead for Sencha GXT at Sencha.
Do you want to stand up, say hi?
>>> Hi there.
[ Applause ]
>>Michael Mullany: Okay.
So before we start just a quick poll.
How many people have developed with GWT, since
you're in the GWT session, right?
Good.
How many people have done an app over 10,000
lines?
50,000 lines?
100,000 lines?
Half a million lines?
Over a million lines of code?
Okay.
That's a good distribution.
Well, one of the reasons that we are excited
about GWT is because it does really help you
with very large applications and very large
teams working together.
We are a company that has about 2 million
worldwide developers in JavaScript and in
Java.
Across all sorts of applications and all sorts
of geographies.
Of that, we have about 400,000 registered
community members on an incredibly active
forum, so we're approaching kind of a million
posts on our forums over time.
We're also expanding geographically pretty
rapidly.
We started on the East Coast, moved to California,
we just opened a Vancouver office and an Amsterdam
office.
I'm not allowed to say we're hiring, so I
won't say that.
[ Laughter ]
>>Michael Mullany: We have a really amazing
array of applications built with Sencha Technologies
with XGS, with Sencha Touch and with GWT.
We have everything from very large clinical
trials management applications to CAs, admin
interfaces to Dell's warehouse management
system, Best Buy's store system, all built
with Sencha technologies.
We're primarily focused on business applications
and very large applications.
That's why people use a very structured framework,
like XGS or GWT.
And our goal is to take -- to really provide
a complete productivity capability from design
time to development run, all the way to deployment.
So Sencha architect, if you stopped by our
sandbox yesterday, is a drag and drop visual
app builder for Sencha Touch and XGS so you
can get mobile and desktop on the same tool.
We are also happy to be working on GWT designer
integration for GXT.
Sencha (indiscernible) is focused on content
animations.
The build side JavaScript frameworks for mobile
and desktop and we have GXT for Java.
Our deployment is the newest thing that we
have.
It's cloud services that basically provide
back end point services like notifications,
authentications, app messaging for mobile
and desktop applications.
Our goal, and I think this is a common thing
across developer bases today, is to as much
as possible provide a single HTML platform
across all of these -- in the multi-device
world, right?
So from phones to tablets to TVs to desktops,
people are trying to create application experiences
that follow you from device to device, that
reuse data, reuse models, reuse business logic,
controller logic as much as possible and that's
really our design point for Sencha Technologies,
whether in JavaScript or in Java.
XGS 4 is our JavaScript framework, I won't
spend much time on it.
It basically provides structure for JavaScript
programmers who want to create large applications
that are pixel perfect across browser.
The companion to that is that Sencha Touch,
which is again a JavaScript framework for
modern mobile devices.
We made a bet that smart phones were the only
phones that smarted and that turned out that
was the case.
We do an awful lot of low level platform code
switching abstraction to make the code base
work across every device that you can think
of.
I mentioned architect and IL.
So on to Sencha GXT, which is a meet for this
room.
GXT started about five years ago as the -- as
Darrell's project and then Darrell joined
Sencha and merged with the Sencha team.
It's basically fully featured, theme-able,
high performance widgets.
It's a true GWT implementation, even more
so in GXT 3 than was the case in GXT 2.
The big thing that GXT brings to the table
is full alignment with GWT conventions in
GXT 3.
But really the thing that knocks you on the
head when you look at GXT is just the sheer
volume and weight of UI widgets that we bring
to the table that you don't have to create
yourself.
There's -- there's literally several hundred
widgets of all types for all types of applications
that work the way that GXT or GWT expects.
So GXT we just completed an enormous release,
our GXT release.
It was just released about six or eight weeks
ago.
It basically takes what we had built ourselves
from our own custom conventions for things
like event handling, all into GWT 2.1 through
2.3 conventions.
So, for example, we now use the cells to render
our trees and our grids and it's much, much
faster and much, much lighter weight.
We have also moved to interface-based design,
so for large applications it's much easier
to create mocks and to do testing.
We've done --
[ Applause ]
>>Michael Mullany: Thank you.
Custom theming, so we now use the appearance
pattern.
We've pulled out theming information out of
the components and out of widgets, so it's
much, much easier to add raw HTML and CSS
styling into your components without standing
on your head.
We also have much improved model support.
So in -- in GXT 2, you basically have to use
our custom data stores and that was the only
way of getting data into an application again
without standing on your head.
Now you can basically pull in -- pull in model
data from plain Java objects or for any beans
that you have.
Much more flexible.
We also added full UI binder support so you
can declare your UI widgets with the UI binder
XML conventions.
Another thing, strongly type layout engine.
One of the big issues with our layouts in
GXT 2 was that you could basically have a
lot of mismatches between a container type
and a layout.
So now we've gone to strongly typed layouts,
so it's much harder to make a mistake and
the compiler will catch it if you try and
associate a layout with a container that doesn't
match it.
And there's a lot of other things in the release,
but basically the whole theme was have a huge
widget library and theming that works with
the new GWT conventions and I think we've
been pretty successful with that.
It's had a great response and a great reception
in the short weeks that we've released it.
And we're really happy to have released it.
So we're actually incredibly excited about
this opening up of GWT with the steering committee.
One of the main reasons that we ended it with
custom conventions in GXT 2 was the fact that
we had no idea what was coming down the road
from the GWT team.
So we had our own event system and I think
it was literally a couple of months afterwards
there was a new event system from GWT that
if we had known was coming, we probably would
have aligned with.
So we're really happy to continue to promote
RIA for Java developers.
We're really excited to be a member of the
steering committee.
We would love to hear you, as a member of
the steering committee, your ideas for how
we can improve GWT going forward.
GWT we feel is the best way for organizations
that are committed to Java to build front
end applications, particularly larger ones,
larger teams, that's what our customer base
tells us why GWT is an awesome solution for
them.
So what are we doing?
We've just finished our GXT release, so it
was pretty huge.
We're just getting around to planning the
next release.
But a couple of things we're doing is making
the appearance implementation that we have
better with a more flexible client bundle,
we are doing some updates to UI binder, and
I think some of our changes have actually
made it into the 2.5 code base.
Theme building.
You know, it's actually a huge request across
our product line, which is how can we do better
visual design without having to hack into
SASS or hack into custom CSS.
Better IDE support and tooling.
So there's some support coming in GWT designer
for GXT 3.
But our goal is to make it easier and easier
to create GXT applications using standard
Eclipse and stand IDEs.
There's much, much more detail into what we've
put into GXT 3, we're really proud of the
release.
Probably the best place to learn more about
it is on our blog, that's the link.
Just Sencha-GXT from our blog.
Also Darrell and myself will be here hanging
around after the session if you want to talk
to us more about GXT.
We're really excited about the directions,
we're really honored that Google has asked
us to participate in the steering committee,
and we hope to be able to serve the GWT community
as best we can in this new role.
So thanks again.
[ Applause ]
>>Ray Cromwell: I would like to ask Joonas
Lehtinen to come up.
He's the C.E.O. of Vaadin, which he has a
fabulous framework.
He's going to tell you all how Vaadin is going
to contribute to GWT and what they're all
about.
>>Joonas Lehtinen: Yeah, I'm really excited
to be here and see where GWT is going at the
moment.
Let's first kind of give a brief intro to
(indiscernible) how we are using GWT and where
that relationship is going in the future.
So you can say that Vaadin is a Java frame
building rich web applications, and as that
it's quite like GWT, but at the same time
it's different from GWT; in Vaadin you're
doing everything from the server side.
It's basically based on three different items.
So first we want to have amazing components,
both as URL components as well as data sources
and data (indiscernible) themes and so on.
So we have really nice set of widgets in the
core product, hundred or so widgets, you can
go to vaadin.com/demo to see that out.
There are also widgets for mobile, Android,
iPhone, iPad.
What I'm mostly excited about is the community
around Vaadin, so there are hundreds of plug-ins
in for Vaadin.
Those plug-ins might be widget outbreaks or
integrations or themes or tools.
Second idea is that they're combining server
side RIA together with (inaudible) so what
is this search?
Look at this, so basically you have five layers
in your (inaudible), so you have the back
end layer and the Web server.
You have communications.
And you're going to have Java to Java compiler,
and then Java to Java within Web browser,
so if you look at GWT, it looks like this,
so this
(indiscernible) four layers, and optionally
you can do on JavaScript on top of that.
Vaadin is quite different.
You are only writing two layers.
You're only writing code on the server side,
so everything on the (indiscernible) layer
and on the browser side is total automatic.
You don't have to write any line of code for
those.
And if you're converting this to Java frameworks,
I like XJS, it's probably the best one out
there at the moment.
So also in here you're writing four layers,
and this is the core of the (indiscernible)
you can kind of skip half -- half of your
program when you're writing in Vaadin.
It actually works like this.
So all of the components have two parts.
You have server side component, it's basically
API that your program is against, so whole
UI is on the server side.
On the client side, you are rendering and
event handling, and that part is totally done
with Web toolkit.
(indiscernible) Third thing, Java, basically
everything in Vaadin is (indiscernible) object,
so all of the components are plain ole objects
just running on the server side in the real
JVM. (indiscernible) you can write UI in any
language out there.
You can use (indiscernible) what have you.
You can use any tooling, any IDs.
You can deploy this to almost any server out
there, most of the clouds, and at the end
of the day, it's just one file, so you can
use that in any web browser.
Just drop that (indiscernible) into a project,
you can start adding UIs with that.
It's (indiscernible) license so it should
be the same license as GWT.
So what's the relation between Vaadin and
GWT?
Let's look at the history.
This is actually quite an old project.
We started in 2001 already.
So we've had 11 years of history behind us.
And then we kind of started to have huge number
of JavaScript code lines on the client side
to render all of those components, and it
turned out to be not that nice, so fortunately
GWT came along and we threw all of that away
and we wrote everything in GWT. (indiscernible)
It was a perfect fit to Vaadin.
Both are written in Java.
Both (indiscernible) oriented and both recorded
across browsers, something very important
for us.
So I could say that this has been kind of
like standing on the shoulder of a giant,
this giant being Google and (indiscernible)
you have been doing a really, really excellent
job, and it has been helping to write quite
a bit, so we haven't had to deal with all
the browser differences ourself.
So you can see this as
our engagement period of five years for us,
and this has been strange engagement because
after five years, we are still in love with
GWT.
I truly think that GWT is the best way of
building Web scripts, Web application on the
client side with Java.
So if you're building a huge application,
there is -- that's the kind of number one
way of doing that on the client side.
But the relationship have been kind of unidirectional.
We have been getting a lot from GWT.
And we haven't been giving too much back.
And I think this is the same for many of us,
so we have been using GWT, we haven't been
giving too much back to GWT.
And I'm really thrilled to see this new development
with the steering committee and more open
process for GWT, so we can come back to GWT,
and I hope in the end this grows to be something
much, much, much bigger than it is today.
So where do we go next?
You have been kind of jumping in five year
leaps.
What's the next leap for us?
So I'm really thrilled to announce the new
study for Vaadin.
We are adding GWT to Vaadin.
So what does it mean?
At the moment we are kind of using GWT as
a dependents.
We are using GWT as a rendering agent behind
the scenes in Vaadin.
What they are doing, they are moving inside
Vaadin, so they're taking copy, putting that
inside Vaadin and maintaining ourselves
(indiscernible) and we, of course, are contributing
all of those back to GWT.
This also means that Vaadin will be combined
with GWT.
So for two days project you can use Vaadin
for that, and as a win developer, a new customer
what's more in there?
There are a couple of things.
But first, there are actually two sides of
Vaadin.
So we have two program modules.
We have server side programming and we have
client side programming.
Server side being optimized for the productivity
and the client side being optimized for the
controlling.
So you get both around 50 reduction of code
lines when you're programming in the server
side as well as all of the wonderful controller
on the platform on the client side.
So you can see that from the developer point
of view we are adding
(indiscernible) components, tools, themes,
but also there's one more theme.
(indiscernible) support, we are serving companies
who are using our technology to build applications,
and now that we are merging GWT in the Vaadin
directly, we are starting the support with
Vaadin.
If (indiscernible) we are a good project for
you.
This is going to be available pretty soon
now.
So we are targeting for the Java 1 release
with Vaadin 7 that will be including GWT,
and it's available as a developer preview
today.
This is an early alpha release, but it's there
for you to try out.
There is a ton of more things to read about
how Vaadin would kind of combine and what
that old aspect, (indiscernible) and read
more about this.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ray Cromwell: Let me switch back to my
slides.
Okay.
So there were a couple of other steering committee
members who couldn't be here, I don't want
to spend too much time.
But Christian Goudreau has developed a wonderful
library called GWT, and he is on the steering
committee as well, and he has some wonderful
things to say, and I'll just leave that up
there for a second for posterity.
As well as Daniel Kurka who has done an incredible
mobile library for web property (indiscernible)
I encourage you to go to n-gwt.com, check
it out.
And he is also on the steering committee.
I'm sure he's going to be focused on making
GWT better for mobile.
Finally, we are hiring.
Believe it or not.
So if you are a unemployed GWT programmer
and you're looking to join Google, and work
on (indiscernible) please send your resume
to Google.com/jobs.
And now I will turn the microphone over to
you.
You're free to ask questions.
[ Applause ]
>>> Hi.
So my first question is about validation.
You said you've implemented the 303 at 2010,
but as for now, our classes in package validation
are marked as experimental, and they say do
not use them in production.
>>Ray Cromwell: Yes.
I'll answer very quickly.
We have recently hired someone to specifically
work on the support in GWT and to make it
100% compatible with the 303 TCK test compatibility
kit.
So if you look at the event logs right now,
you'll see a new guy who is committing -- or
actually one by one he's fixing the TCK test,
and once they pass the TCK, then we'll remove
the experimental tag.
>>> Okay, thanks.
When will 2.5 be released?
>>Ray Cromwell: RC1 is out already.
You can download it now.
Probably in maybe a week or two, the final
version, after we get some bug reports back
and smoke test it more.
Okay.
Thank you.
I'll go over to this one.
>>> Hi, I'm a GIS developer, I use Google
maps to do -- in my projects.
Most of -- I hate JavaScript.
Most of the time I'm looking for a GWT wrappers
around Google maps API.
Are you guys coordinating between the two
teams to always have a GWT library for Google
maps once a new version of Google maps API
comes out?
>>Ray Cromwell: Yeah, a good question.
So, yes, in the past, we have done that, I
believe recently they may have released an
update to the Google API libraries for GWT
which included some support I think for 3.0.
I don't know what state it's in.
Unfortunately, the person who is working on
it, Eric Zundel, left to go to another company,
but we will try to figure out a solution for
that.
It may be that the steering committee takes
it over, like for example, maybe Sencha with
some maps, widgets in there, and they can
basically take on the task of ensuring it's
always up to date.
But we'll find out.
We are definitely concerned about it, because
maps are actually very important.
>>> Thank you.
>>> Hello.
(saying name).
I'm a new developer and our team is mostly
-- we are mostly using intelliJ to develop
and to debug our applications, and the question
is with the new super dev mode, will we be
able to use our favorite IDE to debug applications,
or the only way to do it will be the browser?
>>Ray Cromwell: Right.
Good question.
As you can see.
I am a rabid intelliJ user, I love intelliJ,
and I constantly rag on people at Google that
use eclipse.
The answer is that we are trying to talk to
JetBrains, they've done a lot of good support
in the past to basically get support for source
maps within intelliJ, and based on the outcome
of those talks, if they're willing to do it,
if source maps are implemented or if we had
a plug-in to do it for intelliJ, intelliJ
can already attach to JavaScript debuggers,
so essentially instead of attaching it to
JVM, you attach it to the Chrome debugger,
and all it has to do is use the map to actually
let you match it back into the editor, breakpoint
intelliJ to control Chrome.
It definitely is a possibility to make that
work, and we need to talk to the right people
and make it happen.
>>> All right.
Thanks.
>>Ray Cromwell: Let's go over there.
>>> Hi, I have two questions, actually.
First about the steering committee.
I'm very happy to see that Google is accepting
more external people, but I'm also a little
bit concerned because there are a lot of companies
that have large libraries on the steering
committee.
How do you guaranty that -- these companies
have their own agenda.
How do you guaranty that GWT doesn't become
bloated with their features that --
>>Ray Cromwell: I can answer that.
First thing is that when we initially nominated
them, we told them that we realize that they
have commercial interests, but we would like
steering committee members to also kind of
wear the GWT hat.
So, for example, we're on the GCC committee,
I think, you know, Google participated with
GCC development, and of course people on the
GCC steering committee, they're all commercial
companies or different chip, you know, like
AMD or Intel or whatever, so they have interest,
but the people on the committee usually do
a pretty good job of wearing their GCC hats,
and we expect that the GWT community members
kind of wear their GWT hats so that they have
things that are competitive, they're probably
going to keep them anyway, because that's
their value, but if there's new core features
they need, like new event handlers or new
support for low level operations or there's
bug fixes that they have been forking off
privately in the past to fix, now they will
contribute them back.
The second thing is that the committee is
run by consensus, so if anyone objects, basically,
to a proposal, it doesn't happen.
So we basically all have to agree, and some
people on the committee will be concerned
about bloat, and if, you know, someone wants
to drop in like a two megabyte JavaScript
library, there is going to be some objections.
Is that --
>>> I have a question about the example you
showed with injecting Java code inside the
HTML page, so you type window from lower case
W, it's not class window.
>>Ray Cromwell: That's right.
So -- yeah, so the intelliJ is actually a
really fabulous IDE, (indiscernible) so I
told intelliJ to assume that there's a line
in the code that looks like this, window window
is equal to browser dot get window, and so
that is like implied that's there, and what
happens is the filter, when it's extracting
that code and writing it to disc, it inserts
that line, so the IDE doesn't complain that
that window variable is missing because I
told intelliJ to assume that that's injected.
So that is a feature of intelliJ, so if you're
an eclipse user, you might want to check that
out.
[ Laughter ]
>>Ray Cromwell: Okay.
Let me go to him first.
>>> So another question I wanted to ask is
about kind of release for GWT, what are the
next versions when they will be out and what
features are planned so probably this question
must go to your committee and what will be
the process?
Who will decide?
>>Ray Cromwell: Right.
Excellent question.
And, yes, I should have basically made it
clear that 2.5 will actually be the last official
Google controlled release.
Every new release, GWT 2.6 or GWT 3.0, will
now be basically a steering committee release,
and so the road map, we haven't -- we've just
started our first two or three steering committee
meetings.
We got basic IP issues, and things like that.
We're getting to starting to find a road map,
where are we going to go, go to GitHub or
somewhere else, there's lots of arguments
in the base over that kind of stuff (indiscernible)
and so one thing we're going to discuss is
what's going to go into the next version and
when is it going to be released.
So if you watch GWT steering -- GWT.steering
at Google.com, you can follow along and probably
get some inkling as to when it's going to
happen.
Probably sooner.
Okay.
Any last questions?
All right.
Well, thanks for coming, guys, and I hope
you continue to join GWT.